hello everyone garry kasparov and magnus
carlsen played three games all together
all three games were played in 2004 and
this game here it's the first game
Carlson gets the play against the former
world champion the game was played on
17th of March 2004 it wasn't part of a
tournament it was a part of an opening
ceremony that was before the tournament
the tournament was the day after on the
18th and in the tournament course and
we'll get the play against Kasparov and
the other players two more games so it's
quite an interesting game and since
Kasparov retired in 2005 two of them
never got never got a chance to play
again in an official game but I've seen
Carlson Seine numerous interviews that
he really wouldn't mind playing against
Kasparov in any terms but such such an
event never happened so let's see this
game Kasparov has the white pieces here
and he opens up with c4 cross in place
in Knight to f6
we have Knight to c3 and g6 so the
English opening g3 c5 Bishop to g2 and
9th to c6
we have Knight to f3 d6 and d4 seek
after Sunday for night characters on d4
and Bishop to d7 because part of castles
we have Bishop to g7 both sides simply
developing pieces Knights the c6
Kasparov captures beacon Bishop captures
on c6 and E for now Carlson castles we
have Bishop to e3 a six now and rook to
c1 and Knight to d7 by Carlsen Queen to
e2 b5 now and before by Kasparov and
this is the first moment where things
start to happen probably the best idea
for Carlsen here would be to actually
capture B captures on c4 seems like
somewhat of a counterintuitive move but
after B captures in c4 and Queen
captures Knight to e5 attacking the
Queen also protecting the bishop on c6
and after something like Queen to b3
becomes the b5 attacks the rook now
either you move the rook or probably the
best thing will be to exchange a knight
captures Bishop on b5 and after a
capture some b5
the material is equal Carlson has a nice
rock on it okay
Kasparov does control the C file but you
know it's it's a playable game after B
for Casper cross and went for the
immediate 92 e5 Kasparov played pawn
capture some b5 we have a capture some
b5 Knight capture some b5 Bishop
captures and Queen captures so so far as
part of his upper pond but Carlsen can
capture rook captures an a2 which rook
captures an 82 I really have no idea why
this move wasn't played as black is
perfectly fine here all of his pieces
are nicely developed okay
Kasparov does have a firm grasp on the C
file and it it is kind of difficult to
decide where to what to do with the
Queen would black and how to develop the
rope and f8 so maybe that's the reason
why Carson didn't go for this rook
captures an a2 but the night is
perfectly fine any five okay black wool
if he white will eventually kick it with
f4 if he wants to although this will
open up his King a bit but instead after
this Queen to be five by Kasparov
Carlson didn't capture the point he
played Queen to b8 probably with the
idea that if Kasparov captures the Queen
Queen captures rook captures now Carlson
will win back either this one or the
other pawn or both of them but after
this Queen to be eight and now
Kasparov played a 4 and a 4 is a very
dangerous move if Carlson plays any slow
move other than capturing the Queen then
Kasparov will play Bishop to b6 and
after Bishop to b6 he will push a 4 and
the bishop and two points will be
completely protected and Kasparov will
keep the two best pawns
so after this Queen to be queen to be
eight and a four Carlsen captured Queen
captures and we have a capture some b5
now Kasparov has a past beep on okay
here's to two pawns but they're doubled
here rook F to b8 was played and b6 back
as part of the bishop is now nicely
protecting this pawn and b6 and this is
the critical moment of the game here a
crossing has to play rook to a4 after
something like rook to a for this comes
you're not allowing as part to put b7
which tempo also you're attacking the b4
pawn and after something like f4 after
kick tonight then b7 rook captures and
now e5 you open up a discovered attack
from the bishop to the rook after rook
captures the other pawn now rook to c7
attacking the knight and after Knight
moves rook captures on e7 and white is
clearly better but if is it enough to
win the game it's it's hard to say if
black captures white will recapture with
the f1 and then open up the attack from
the other rook to the f7 pawn so like it
doesn't really have this option it's
clearly a better position for white he
does have the bishop prepare but again
it's hard to say if this is enough to
win the game
but after this b6 move by Casper of
course in place a move that is the
absolute blunder he plays Knight to g4
he attacks this Bishop that is
protecting the pawn and b6 with the idea
that the bishop doesn't really have
anywhere to go DeForest covered by the
bishop on g7 C 5 is covered by the pawn
so Carson idea is to capture the bishop
and then capture the pawn and b6 but
here cuz part of simply plays b7 and in
this position Magnus Carlsen resigned at
the game why did he resign it's pretty
pretty obvious your rook is attacked on
a egg if you move the rook for example
something like rook to a4 going for the
pond and simply rook to c7 and you're
losing the game if you capture them pawn
captures with Queen this comes with
check if you don't capture if you block
with with the bishop then simply rook
captures rook and you've lost the rook
on the other hand after this b7 move if
you capture it then simply 5 and this
bishop is capturing it at least this
rook or district and again you're
winning the exchange and you're losing
the game so after this b7 this is moved
21 Magnus Carlsen resigned the game and
the first game two of them ever played
Kasparov was the obvious winner the
winner after 21 moves so you've probably
seen Magnus Carlsen destroy some top
grandmasters when he was very young by
the age of 13 and 14 he
already I mean destroying some very
strong players so why do you think he
succumbed this way how did this terrible
blunder happen was it just a brilliant
game by Garry Kasparov or was a 14 year
old Magnus Carlsen simply too nervous
playing the world champion for the world
for the first time so that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it I will show the
other two games that were actually
played in this rapid tournament I would
like to thank Kenneth McCabe for a
contribution thank you from Scotland and
thank you all for watching I will I will
see you soon